Rule one of cooking, always use a sharp knife, so...
...make sure you get that sorted out before we go live.
It's far harder working in a kitchen with a blunt knife than it is with a sharp knife.
The secret behind keeping a sharp knife, sharpen it before and every time you use it.
First, grip the steel. It really comes about holding the steel.
Imagine you're holding a tennis racket or you're playing squash.
Got to be really comfortable with it.
Now, 45 degrees. Confident grip, confident grip with the knife.
This is the birth of the steel. Really important you keep your fingers behind there.
You never grip a steel with your fingers over that...
...'cause the knife comes back in. You've just lost a finger.
Always grip behind.
Nice long strokes so we get the whole of the blade over the steel.
Stroke, and we start from the bottom to the top.
So there, across. There, across. Slow strokes over the top of the steel.
And then, come back underneath. Then, back underneath. Then, back underneath.
Away. And then, start the rhythm. It's like playing the drum.
Away, away, away, away. Nice and slow.
Away, back underneath and get really nice and comfortable.
And relax your arms, and relax your wrist.
Under, over, under, over, under, over.
It's so dangerous working in the kitchen with a blunt knife. You can cause so much damage.
Working with a sharp knife is ten times quicker, more efficient.
Now, that's ready to start chopping.